tonight we start with President Barack
Obama ignoring a major warning in 2014
that Russia would try to in fact
interfere in America's elections so what
did Obama do in 2016 2015 2014 did even
try to stop it absolutely not instead
just weeks before the election listen to
what then President Obama said I have
never seen in my lifetime or in modern
political history any presidential
candidate
trying to discredit the elections and
the election process before votes have
even taken place it's unprecedented it
happens to be based on no facts there is
no serious person out there who would
suggest somehow that you could even you
could even rig America's elections
there's no evidence that that has
happened in the past
or that there are instances in which
that will happen this time and so I
invited mr. Trump to stop whining and go
try to make his case to get votes no
serious person really Barack Obama he
owes you the American people tonight an
explanation why didn't he know and
better yet how did he not know when he
was warned in 2014 that sounds like a
dereliction of duty so it's time for
President Obama to start talking maybe
even under oath and now that you have
that important background information it
makes sense why the president is firing
back against this completely biased news
media in this country and the democratic
party that have wanted to destroy him
from day one over this phony Russia
collusion conspiracy theory now the
facts do not matter to the left they
have now managed to convince themselves
by repeating their talking points in
their echo chamber that somehow in some
way president from colluded with the
Russians even though as we have
repeatedly pointed out long over a year
to this day there is no evidence of
trump Russia collusion now the only
concrete evidence of collusion with
Russia that we have is Hillary Clinton
and are bought and paid for dossier
that's filled with Russian lies Russian
government lies and propaganda and
salacious details that were never
verified she used that bought that to
influence an election so just like he
always does President Trump he's
fighting back and he's fighting back on
Twitter to react to Muller's indictment
of these 13 Russian Nationals for the
2016 election meddling and the president
writes quote how funny that the fake
news media doesn't want to say the
Russian group was formed in 20
14 long before my run for president
maybe they knew I was going to run even
though I did not know Robert Muller's
indictment clearly lays out that this
Russian attempt to influence the
election it started in 2014 under
Obama's watch and he was warned and he
did nothing to stop it
in fact by the way go back to 2012
during a presidential debate remember
Barack Obama mocking Mitt Romney for
saying Russia still posed a very serious
foreign policy threat Mitt Romney was
right Obama was wrong and of course the
media ignored ignored all the key facts
and findings in the Muller indictment
now you and the media you corrupt people
in the media you need to listen closely
very closely to what the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein said while
announcing the charges on Friday pay
very close attention you may actually
learn something now there is no
allegation in this indictment that any
American was a knowing participant in
this illegal activity there is no
allegation in the indictment that the
charge conduct altered the outcome of
the 2016 election after the election the
defendants allegedly staged rallies to
support the president-elect while
simultaneously staging rallies to
protest his election for example the
defendants organized one rally to
support the president-elect and another
rally to impose to oppose him both in
New York on the same day wait did I just
hear it no Americans were wittingly
involved in this Russian effort now the
main goal of Russia was to so widespread
political discord and after the election
these Russians cyber trolls what did
they do they were trying to undermine
the president elect Donald Trump they
were organizing dueling Trump rallies in
New York City and an anti Trump rally in
Charlotte North Carolina instead of
focusing what is actually in this Muller
indictment what Rob Rosenstein said that
corrupt media of yours they're trying to
use it to further their fake news rush a
conspiracy narrative take a look we have
the proof really the goal here was
simple damage Hillary Clinton and elect
Donald Trump and the
Russians allegedly went to great lengths
he's found this incredible network of
meddling and now he has kind of a
stronger basis on which to go and look
at collusion that emails this didn't
deal with it with the hacking of the US
and the issue of obstruction of justice
what's going on here is establishing an
underlying crime and then anything house
henceforth is going to be conspiracy to
obstruct or to collude there may well be
information there may well be lots of
evidence that there was not only
unwitting but witting assistance from
the Trump campaign I think that the
president has continued to advocate
responsibility here about leading the
country in response to an attack on the
most core fundamental part of our
democracy are free and fair elections
he's the dumbest attorney on TV what the
destroy Trump media also missed were key
points and pieces of information about
what is not in the Muller indictment it
has nothing about Donald Trump colluding
with the Russians by the way we still
have zero evidence I'm waiting it says
nothing about members of the Trump
campaign colluding with the Russians it
says nothing about Donald Trump jr.
colluding with the Russians it says
nothing about for the president
obstructing justice liberal media are
you paying attention do you even care
about the truth now President Trump has
been saying that fact over and over and
over again take a look
there has been no collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russians or Trump and
Russians no collusion but bottom line
they all say there's no collusion and
there is no collision there was
absolutely no collusion everybody knows
it let's put it this way
there is absolutely no coloration that
has been proven
there is absolutely no collusion I
didn't make a phone call to rush you I
have nothing to do with Russia everybody
knows it what has been shown is no
collusion no collusion there's been
absolutely there's been absolutely no
collusion now the president also tweeted
this weekend quote I never said Russia
did not meddle in the election I said it
may be Russia or China or another
country or group or it may be a
400-pound genius sitting in bed and
playing with his computer the Russian
hoax was that the Trump campaign
colluded with Russia and it never did
and then he added quote if it was the
goal of Russia to create discord
disruption chaos within the US then with
all the committee hearings
investigations and party hatred they
have succeeded beyond their wildest
dreams they are laughing their asses off
in Moscow Get Smart America think about
it the president's right for over a year
Russia has in fact been laughing at us
Democrats the media have been playing
right into Putin's hands by creating
chaos and political discord just what
they wanted and frankly it's working
better than Russia could have ever
dreamed of now that is what this Russian
effort was all about causing chaos
political unrest in this country now the
Washington Examiner is Byron York he'll
join us later tonight he is out with a
great article which is entitled a non
alarmist reading of the Muller Russia
indictment in the piece York makes some
very key points namely that Russian
started all of this in 2014
hmm Donald Trump wasn't running the
focus was on damaging Hillary Clinton
remember because everyone thought she
was gonna win all of you in the media
you were laughing at the idea of Donald
Trump running now Byron York also cites
figures from the Senate Intelligence
Committee that in the key battleground
states of Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania the Russians only spent
$3,000 on Facebook ads now also the
indictment is very vague about how much
these Russian trolls spent on social
media ads it only says they spent quote
thousands every month now that number is
small when you compare it to the
combined 2.4
billion dollars that the Clinton and
Trump campaign spent during the election
mostly Clinton that's not that much
money also tonight a Facebook executive
he's sounding off about the Russia
investigation his name is Rob Goldman
he's the vice president of advertising
at Facebook he set the record straight
on Twitter over the weekend writing
quote the majority of the Russian ads
spent happened after the election
they're spent now we shared that fact
but very few outlets have covered it
because it doesn't align with the main
media narrative of Trump and the
election and he goes on quote the main
goal of the Russian propaganda and
misinformation effort is to divide
America by using our institutions like
freedom of speech social media against
us it is stoke fear and hatred amongst
Americans it is working incredibly well
we are quite divided as a nation even
Facebook is throwing cold water on the
media's fake news narrative about
Muller's indictment now let's get back
to Obama's failure to stop this Russian
interference Congressman Devin Nunez
back in 2014 he raised a red flag that
yes Vladimir Putin needed to be watched
closely but Obama didn't seem to care
and even two weeks before the election
he's lecturing Trump stop whining it
could never happen here now remember as
NBC News pointed out Obama didn't do
more to combat Russia he thought Hillary
was a shoo-in why interrupt this and
what's even more disturbing is that
there were even earlier warning signs
from Russia we have been telling you on
this program how flat amir putin had
Russian operatives inside America right
here on our soil and how they were
involved in a sophisticated plot it
started in 2009 it had a main objective
to get a foothold in America's uranium
market we actually had an FBI informant
we now know his name Douglas Campbell
and we've been telling you about this
guy this guy now has testified before
three congressional committees and
literally he was uncovering at the time
in 2009 and 10 that Putin and his
operatives were involved in bribery and
kickbacks and money laundering and
tearing and extortion all while corrupt
uranium one deal that was all being
approved 18 months later he couldn't
understand why they didn't take his
intelligence and that gave Russia a
hostile foreign actor control of 20% of
America's uranium who would be this
stupid to do this apparently Obama and
Hillary Clinton and Eric Holder and then
at the time the FBI Director Robert
Muller and by the way Muller when are
you gonna answer questions about this
America already we don't have enough
uranium the foundational material for
nuclear weapons why would we give 20% to
a hostile nation Russia and a hostile
actor Putin it never made sense it
doesn't make sense and here we are years
later and the media the Democrats they
are shocked they're just flabbergasted
that Russia would ever even dare to try
to influence our election even though as
I just explained they were easily able
to be involved in bribery extortion
kickbacks money laundering and secure
20% of America's uranium why would they
stop they already know we're being
stupid plus has the left forgotten what
President Obama tried to do to Israel Oh
influencing elections is wrong tell that
to the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu America's closest ally in the
Middle East
remember the congressional investigation
found that back in 2014
an Israeli political group used three
hundred thousand taxpayer dollars the
Obama State Department integrand to
create a political apparatus to try and
defeat our closest ally in the Middle
East the Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu and it doesn't stop there
the US if it's so wrong we've been
involved in influencing elections that
day dates back to places like Italy Iran
Guatemala Chile Nicaragua and those are
just a few examples and take a look at
what the former CIA director james
Woolsey told Laura Ingraham about the US
and how we interfere in foreign
elections take a look have we ever tried
to meddle in other countries elections
Oh probably but it was for the good of
the system in order to avoid
the Communists from taking over for
example in Europe in 47 48 49 the Greeks
and the Italians we only for a very good
do that do a vine video and as former
CIA for a very good cause I'm an
interesting democracy now let me be
clear I'm not saying America should not
be doing this I do believe we ought to
be doing this on a regular basis I
believe in intelligence I believe in
covert operations plausible deniability
I believe in at all thank God we have
good people in the CIA the intelligence
community FBI and others military that
are doing this every day but it's beyond
naive to think that this wouldn't happen
to us especially given Russia's success
with uranium 1 back in 2009 and 10 and
another by the way is you know acting
surprised by the Russian election
meddling all these people in the media
they're either flat-out lying to you or
they're just totally ignorant you pick
the either the Obama administration was
not prepared for Russian trying to
interfere our election or his
administration made a choice to ignore
the threat probably the latter
probably because they thought Hillary
was going to win it's that simple and
that's why President Obama tonight if
you really care about this owes you the
American people an explanation now also
breaking at this hour
now that robert muller is indicted the
13 Russian nationals very serious legal
questions of being raised about Hillary
Clinton about the DNC about the law firm
Perkins cuy about fusion GPS and about
that former British spy Christopher
Steele now think about this look at this
headline from the website law and crime
quote does Muller indictment mean
Clinton campaign can be indicted for
Christopher Steele wait a minute is
there a double standard the article
makes some fascinating legal points for
in for example Robert Muller indicted
the Russian trolls in part for failing
to register as foreign agents and for
not reporting their activities to the
Federal Elections Commission okay if
that's the legal standard that Robert
Muller is set up fine then the Special K
should also be looking into Hillary
Clinton the DNC fusion GPS Perkins cuy
and Christopher Steele and here's why
Steele is a foreign citizen a former
British spy he was paid by fusion GPS
through that law firm
Perkins Cooley the law firm tied to the
Clinton campaign in the DNC we've not
seen anything to suggest that Steele was
a registered foreign agent that he
reported to the FCC that he's being
compensated okay if that's all true
given that information well that would
mean the fusion GPS Perkins cuy the DNC
the Clinton campaign and Christopher
Steele should all be in serious legal
jeopardy at a very minimum Muller should
be investigating them or is there a
double standard mr. Muller now there's
already been a complaint filed with the
FEC against the Clinton campaign and the
DNC accusing them of violating campaign
finance laws for failing to disclose the
up to 12 million dollars that was
shelled out to fund the dossier and we
know that the dossier was used to
influence the election that was the
whole point to use lies to manipulate
you the American people we also know now
that was also used by the FBI to get
that FISA warrant to spy on the Trump
campaign and in an election year in
opposition party candidate now that is
the only evidence we have after over a
year going on a year and a half of
Russian collusion in 2016 that we know
exists